( intro music )
( upbeat music )
Asher Jay: For me it's about
how can I get people
to feel that effortless
connection to nature.
Technically speaking
this is all part of our
biological and evolutionary
development.
This is our story.
No matter
what we do to the world
life still finds a way to
express itself.
That is pure magic to me.
That is nature
finding expression
against all the odds
that we impress upon it.
That, to me, is hope.
( applause )
People often ask me
if I find it to be a
bit of a contradiction,
being such an
impassioned advocate
for wilderness and wildlife,
yet choosing to reside
in the most curated habitat
for man, New York City.
And I often reply to them,
'Not particularly so'
because, while I can understand
that living in a city
easily allows people
to disengage themselves
from the realities
of the world around them,
I think
it is the very same city
that has helped me find
this intrinsic connection,
no matter how far removed I am
from nature, to nature.
So when I walk home
from the gym
on a fine Friday evening
through Madison Square Park,
the smallest patch of green
in New York,
and I encounter fireflies
flitting about at dusk,
that is pure magic to me.
That is nature,
finding expression
against all the odds
that we impress upon it.
That to me is hope.
And that shows me
that life is resilient
which inspires me
to do what I do.
So, when the
BP oil-spill happened,
I felt compelled
to participate,
to take the dialogue
a step further
than just feeling
like this passive voice
in a much larger system.
Because an individual does
have impact,
granted that it is...
you know,
a small drop in the ocean
but every drop counts,
and I think together
we build up
a much larger momentum.
And when the BP oil-spill
happened,
at that point I was at the
peak of my fashion career.
So, I had just launched
a label,
I wanted to take that
the next step forward,
but then when this unfolded
I was just
completely debilitated.
I was in my bed sobbing
for about a month
and I realized that I couldn't
just go on with my life
turning a blind eye to
what was happening
in my immediate reality
and just being a victim
to what seemed at that time
a failing system.
Don't get me wrong, I still
think it's a failing system
but I feel like I have a
much larger voice and stake
in what is happening around me
simply on account of
taking responsibility.
And this particular work,
along with six others
that I created,
cast light on
how we fuel life with death.
And it was a way for me to
condense information
and package it into
the simplest format possible.
Something that is
two dimensional,
contrast positive space
with negative space,
which is to say, you know,
what remains,
what's worth protecting and
what has been lost forever.
Because unless you show people
what is there against
what isn't,
there is no contrast,
there's no understanding
of the baseline
that has shifted,
which seems
the constant problem
with the generation today.
They just don't know
that we have lost so much
in the last 10 years,
in the last 20 years.
And when I created these works
I decided to take that
leap of faith,
which led me to Africa,
and I spent the entire
two months that we were there
basically on a
one-woman crusade
picking up garbage
everywhere I went.
And I would drop it off
at different ranger posts
every evening.
You do this for a week
and word travels,
because the next thing I knew
when I was shifting
from one resort to the next,
people would call ahead
and tell them, like,
'She is going to come and
inspect your sewage plan,
how you dispose of
your waste.
And she is going to take issue
with everything,
so be prepared,
she's coming over.'
And so they would welcome me
and show me...
And they'd be, like,
'This is what you need to see'
and I'm like, 'No, I'm going to
do it on my terms
and I will see
what I want to see
when I want to see it.'
But it is just the idea of
one person having that voice
and that travelling within
two months
across the board
in Tanzania and Kenya.
So much so, people thought
I was the part of UN by then,
that I was with--
affiliated with
numerous other organizations,
that I was in
on this, like,
insider conspiracy bust,
and what that culminated in
was me coming back to New York
with a whole lot of garbage,
which was a really interesting
conversation with TSA.
And I wound up,
you know,
clearing immigration somehow
and wound up in New York
and I used all this garbage
to create a line of artwork
called 'Shadowed Heirlooms'.
And the entire series
focused on
how infrastructure growth
and population growth
was infringing upon
wild habitat,
and how all of the trees
that I saw,
the open grasslands
that we think of
when we think of
the dark continent
and the lost wilderness
of Africa,
is completely bestrewn
and bejeweled
with plastic bags and
consumers brand packaging
from European and
American markets.
So I would see L'Oreal,
I'd see Tampax,
I'd see diaper bags,
cosmetic companies...
Things that you would
recognize from here
in Africa,
in the open grassland.
And zebras and giraffes
chewing on this.
And that's not
what you think of
when you think of Africa
and that was such a shame
and it really broke my heart.
And so I created this
line of work
which led me to meet
Louie Psihoyos
and Ric O'Barry
shortly after,
like I said,
the path of least resistance,
and that opened up
a whole different dialogue
which was all about oceans
and what was happening
to cetaceans being exploited
for a spectacle,
so this whole idea of
not just capturing dolphins
and orcas to show them
in these confined spaces
where they are held for
long periods of time,
completely abused
and out of context
because they have
a large social context,
these are highly sentient
beings,
they know
how to relate on a,
like, a deep emotional level
and they live in a culture,
sort of as how humans do.
And to pull them out
of that whole context
and show them as
one off is not--
is to take away
the very essence and spirit
of that animal,
is to break that spirit.
And so they're just shadows
of what cetaceans would be
in the wild in captivity.
So when you go to SeaWorld
and you support that show,
you are not getting
any kind of education.
All you are seeing is an orca
that is not an orca any more,
that has been
completely broken
in every form that's possible,
psychologically traumatized.
And you are paying
a dollar for that
and that's not okay.
And if we don't
condone slavery,
and we don't condone this
sort of abuse in human beings,
we shouldn't being doing that
for other species.
So I decided to get involved
with this whole campaign
and created a series of works
and once again trying
to condense
and fold information into
two-dimensional layouts
that will
immediately translate
in a glimpse to
largest audience possible.
So this was as simple
as interpreting
what the Japanese flag
would look like
by placing
sort of a bloody spot
that's bleeding out
in the center of the flag.
And that also spells the word
'The Cove'.
And not only did I see
garbage unfolding in Africa
but every time I went
scuba diving or snorkeling
in any ecosystem,
all I encountered was plastic.
So I started creating
these simple animations,
this is the other aspect
of my career,
that I haven't told
very many people,
is that I don't know how to do
half of the things I do.
And so when I wake up,
thank God for Google
and thank God for, like,
'How To For Dummies'
because if I didn't, like,
look up these, like,
simple tutorials
there would be no way
in which I even knew
how to animate.
So this particular animation
is one of my early animations,
just to connect
consumer choices
and a simple thing such as
acquiring a plastic bag
in your life
and how that translates
into affecting
a larger ecosystem
in our world.
( piano music)
And so
as I was saying earlier with
life being resilient, I mean--
And this is the other thing
I have to say
about my life is that most of
the mail I get is just garbage
and the one thing
that I got recently
is a plastic bottle from
Long Island
that was covered in barnacles.
So this is once again
a sign of life being resilient.
So, no matter what
we do to the world,
life still finds a way to
express itself.
All we need to do is
give it a chance.
So, for me it's about
how can I get people
to feel that effortless
connection to nature.
And one of the things
that I did is starting to
embed data
that is otherwise hard
for a layperson to feel
a visceral connection with,
through what I can create.
And this particular image
is a time-face
because it shows you
a boat at every hour,
which shows you that
exploitation
occurs around the clock,
day and night.
But also the fact that
there is pie chart
embedded within it
through dotted black lines
and only three percent of
global fisheries
is in recovery.
The rest of it is either
moderately exploited,
heavily exploited or
just going extinct,
on the brink of extinction.
That is not okay,
especially when
over one billion people
in the world
rely on fish
as a protein source.
And this particular image
just shows you
what's wrong with
this picture.
All of the life that is
in the ocean
is actually on land.
Taking it a step further,
getting people to connect
with the idea of barcodes.
You know, the fact that
we slap on a barcode
onto any living creature
and then selling it.
We sell everything
we can get our hands on.
And we say that--
We somehow single out China
and say that
China is the one
who is doing this.
It's not one nation,
it's not one type of people,
we all do it.
So, the other work
that I started creating,
the other line of work
I started creating,
is along the lines of
climate change.
Because habitat loss
and the fact that weather
patterns are shifting locally
is resulting in species
migrating early
and not having the food supply
they need
to nourish themselves so
they can go to the next stop.
So it's like, along the way,
the entire chain gets broken.
And this particular work
is about
how climate can march for
itself, if it could,
but since it can't,
we need to take a stand for it.
And, Climate March is not
just about climate.
It's about biodiversity loss
and decline of wildlife
in wilderness areas
around the world.
And so rising sea levels
is not just a threat to us,
it's the threat to
every type of organism,
things that we have not even
discovered yet.
There are five species up
top in the exclamation marks
because they are
recent discoveries.
And beneath that is all
the species we have known
of that are in question,
heading towards
the brink of extinction.
And in the last row you have
species that have been
driven to extinction
in the last five years,
including the Western
Black Rhinoceros
and the Javan Tiger.
And this is the
same fate that faces
all the other megafauna
in question.
So then I decided
to take the opportunity
that was given to me
to create a Fabergé egg,
for the Big Egg Hunt
to speak to these issues.
and I created
this particular image
called the 'iStorm Egg',
which shows you
a Sandy hurricane
satellite image.
It's the eye of the storm.
And on top of that
I've overlaid biodiversity,
eyes of biodiversity
from around the world,
including human beings.
So you see all these eyes
staring back at you,
they are silent witnesses
to what's happening
to their habitat,
to the world around them.
And this particular egg,
I'm actually going to
build on it further.
Because one of the things
I think that's lacking
is that we think
'It's going to be okay.'
That somehow we are
going to get through this,
technology will come up
with an answer.
There's some shortcut
that we are going to hit.
There isn't going to be any.
And unless we understand that
this distant cataclysmic
future is a closer reality,
something that's palpable
in the immediate future,
we are never going to
really get down
to doing something about it.
So, one of the ideas
we're bouncing around
with a whole bunch of people
is this idea of creating
a black box,
a sensory depravation chamber.
And within the black box
I'm going to place this egg
and have an immersive
soundtrack
that is going to
basically be
different audio channels
of wild calls.
And the closer
a person gets to the egg,
the more those wild calls
will start diminishing.
And then you'll have
that being replaced
by anthropogenic noise.
And there's going to be
a tipping point in place,
so when there's enough
anthropogenic noise
replacing the audio channels
of wild calls,
it's going to trigger
a hurricane.
So you realize that
it's your interaction
with that egg that's resulting
in that hurricane.
And the other aspect of this
is also going to be that
there's going to be a video
installation along the walls.
So I'm going to place
an entire track
of eyes opening and closing
from around the world.
And those too will go...
dark as we get
closer to the egg
and as you're triggering
the hurricane.
Ultimately resulting in a
completely black chamber
devoid of sound,
devoid of life.
And that's what
we are resulting in.
So, I think if you are
in that space,
for even a moment,
you are going to realize
that that dead-zone
was created by you,
and that's the kind of
dead-zone
you are perpetuating
in the world around you.
So, that has led me because--
since I don't say no
to any of the issues,
it keeps leading me
further down the rabbit hole.
And this stumble has led me to
the Denver Ivory Crush,
which the whole intent
behind it
was to 'destroy'
the stockpile.
And I put that within quotes
because that's not
what has happened, eventually.
They recently announced
a design challenge,
a call to artists
and designers
to create something
out of this crushed ivory.
And many people, including me,
back when I went to it,
I thought when they were
going to crush the ivory,
that it was going to be
completely powdered, like--
like utterly destroyed.
And that's not what happened.
You have giant shards of ivory
that can still be used
for something.
So anything that's cast
out of this material
is still going to look
beautiful,
even though they say it's
'educational',
which by the way
is going to be
the next big loophole
that Asian markets
are going to exploit.
'Educational use of ivory.'
I mean, how are you going to
define that in other markets?
It's hard enough to regulate
this illicit trade,
a trade that basically allows
for death to perpetrate
en masse.
50,000 elephants culled a year
for this particular product
that is not even really needed
in any capacity
by human beings.
It doesn't-- It's not integral
to our survival.
And the other thing with that
is the ban and the moratorium.
When you have a moratorium
in place,
all it says is the market is
closed for now
and the doors will open
eventually.
So, the prices will
build in the meanwhile.
And you can just hold on
to your stockpile
and release it
when the time is right.
And with a ban, it says,
'You made a ( bleep )
investment, this is over.
Get over yourself'
And it's done.
You know, we are not going to
kill any more elephants
for this ridiculous trade.
Right now, the trade,
what it's doing
is infringing upon
not only their habitat
but also killing
the individuals that are part--
An integral part of
a functioning society
of elephants.
So, that results
in a loss of information
being handed down from
generation to generation.
So all you are looking at
when you look at a herd
when you go on safari now
is sub-adults and their calves.
It's like looking at
teenage mothers
with kids and they don't know
what to do with them.
And that's not
an 'elephant' society,
that's not an elephant herd
as it used to be 50 years ago
or 100 years ago.
So when people come up
to me and say,
you know, 'What do I do
with the piece of ivory
that I have in my house?
A belt-buckle or a statue,
you know,
it's like the entire
fur argument.
If you don't destroy it,
you have it in your house
in any capacity,
whether it's pre-moratorium
or post-moratorium,
it doesn't matter.
Because ultimately
what you're doing
is saying that it's okay
to have ivory in some way.
That it's okay to encourage
the death of an elephant
for this.
And that's not okay.
Because when you wear
fur from the past,
you are saying it's okay
to scale up demand
in the present
for that product.
A product that is not
integral to our survival.
And so with the
Ivory Crush now
I'm trying to suggest
that we cremate
the crushed raw material
and use the cremated material
to cast a memorial
instead of creating
a sculpture of any sort.
Because with a memorial
at least you have a space
where people could come to,
to mourn loss
as opposed to just looking at
something that's beautiful
and supposedly educational.
And, it's like how do you use
the right vocabulary
to reach a new demographic,
because there's no
point preaching to the choir.
And for that you need to
figure out
how you package
your information
and what you're trying to
say through it.
So, this particular work...
it's a peek-preview,
it's not released yet.
And I started working with
Dereck and Beverly Joubert,
who are
Explorers-in-Residence here,
to cast a light
on what's happening to rhinos
in Kruger National Park,
which is a high
poaching incidence area.
And we are trying to currently
translocate 100 Rhinos
from Kruger to Botswana.
And so this particular
animation
is going to cast a light on
how we can go about,
you know, funding and helping
their efforts on the fields.
( rhinoceros sounds )
( gun shots )
( rhinoceros whining )
( gun shot )
( rhinoceros sounds )
So reinterpreting
the rhino out of the I/O icon
reaches engineers.
Like my roommate's boyfriend
who came into the room,
for the first time in his life
was suddenly awakened
and, like, was actively
engaged by
what was happening to rhinos
for the first time.
He's asking me
information about
what was happening to rhinos
in Kruger National Park.
With this particular image
I tried to get the cat
to stare back, to connect
to the audience member,
to the viewer.
It's about extending
what the cat can do for itself
because its voice--
It has a voice.
They're not voiceless,
it's just that
we're not listening.
And with big cats in specific,
it has become a
recent passion of mine simply
because of the way
in which we have allowed
for lot things to happen
with them.
And now this model
is being suggested
as a replicable model for
rhinos and other species.
To farm tigers is not okay.
To farm any wildlife
is not okay.
And we are just standing by,
as China continues to have
tiger farms upon tiger farms.
Thailand. Vietnam.
And they have 5,000 tigers
in captivity right now.
And they are kept in
appalling conditions.
Like sardines in a can.
So, this particular trade
for tiger bone wine
and tiger bone cake
has become a recent
focus of mine.
Simply because it's not
just about tigers,
they're also harvesting
lions in Africa
for the bone trade.
And neither of these things
have any medicinal value,
has any kind of value
for the human being.
And, honestly speaking,
every single thing
that we create
can have a synthetic version,
that is generated in a lab,
because we're capable
of innovation
so it's really discrediting us
and our ability to be
the 'intelligent' species.
We're not being
intelligent at all.
And every tiger is perfect.
It has to be.
Because it's the only way that
it's going to function
in the ecosystem
it was born for.
To predate and do
what a tiger can,
only a tiger can do.
And so to take that
away from a tiger,
by replacing the stripes
with bars
and placing it
behind those bars
is to break
the very essence of a tiger
just as we broke
the essence of an orca
by placing it within a tank.
And to take that
a step further,
talking about how species
connect to the land
and how they sculpt and change
the fabric of that land.
And how that land
ties back into
the essence and
core of a tiger.
It's back and forth.
There is a give and take
in that relationship,
which we don't
understand at all.
So we think we can play,
sort of, God
for the entire context, right?
We can pull things out,
put things in,
shoot things down.
It's all good,
it will recover,
it will figure itself out
because we know best.
But we don't know anything.
And we don't have the humility
to acknowledge that.
So this particular work
once again cast a light
on, sort of, how the ecosystem,
the Savannah,
the grassland is an implicit
part of a lion's soul.
Soul is a very tricky term
to use
because it has
religious connotations
but like there is a
larger sense of self and being
within an animal that
should be acknowledged.
And tying that back
into the idea of, you know,
are we willing to be
clear in our communication
about how we
grant certain rights
and personhood to ourselves,
even to our corporations,
but not willing to extend that
towards animals.
We keep them in vertical bars,
in vertical stripes,
but we keep horizontal stripes
and freedom for ourselves.
And why is that?
Why do we have this
bifurcated view
of how we associate
with our own selves?
Because, technically speaking,
this is all part of
our biological
and evolutionary development,
this is our story.
And we're just fragmenting
parts of our selves
and saying that we can't
afford those rights
and extend those rights
to other beings.
And that's just incomplete
as a picture.
So these images again
show that
we've taken the voice away
from wildlife
but we managed to take a stand
for ourselves.
So everything happens
in relation to us.
And currently
there is a court case going on
to basically cast a light
on the need
to impart rights to animals.
At least to certain animals
that have been proved
to have higher
cognitive function.
So, cetaceans, elephants
and great apes.
So this is about giving
equality to both man and ape.
And the reason
why I did it in blue and red
is for the Republican
and Democratic vote.
And the image
to the other side is called
'Deep Rooted Truths'.
Because it connects us
to the tree of life and
also to the DNA,
the helix,
that shows our evolution
and how we connect to nature
on, sort of, an inherent
cellular level.
And that we are in balance
with a much larger system,
if we choose to be.
And this particular image,
I actually created
as part of this same series.
You will notice
the same colors,
you know, trickling through
and trickling across.
And the reason
why I created this was
because I went on a dive
in Isla Mujeres
and I saw 'Silent Evolution',
which is an artwork
of sculptures
that have been dropped
into the ocean
and the bio-rock allows for
corals to grow on it.
And I love the way in which
life found expression again
on a human form and
extended from the human form
and reached back into
its ecosystem.
And interacted with
other species.
So I found this way of showing
that we're all
made of the same stuff
and that we all flow in and
out of one another,
if only we were awake for it.
And tying that further
into the cladogram,
so it's, sort of, our lineage
and our larger story.
So this is where we come from.
This is who we are.
And if it was a
part of our past,
it should be part of our
present and future.
And so by granting
these rights to wild,
what we're doing is
acknowledging who we really are.
And granting those rights
in its entirety to ourselves.
In the end I think
the reason why I do
everything that I do
is because I want to
influence the one thing
that I know will have impact
on nature and the fate of
nature going forward.
And that's you.
So if you don't hold
yourselves accountable
and you don't plug yourselves
into this dialogue,
there is no hope.
You can have numerous people,
coming up here and
giving these speeches,
but that doesn't translate
into anything,
unless you yourself
get involved.
And stop part-timing
conservation.
Thank you.
( applause )
( outro music )